here comes green claws here comes Korean
closet wrap and kimchi under your tree
Christmas Santa Claus father Christmas
old man Santa Claus do you think Santa
eats his reindeer he's fat today we are
going to try to become Santa that seems
hard
I have very unmagical Christmas memories
I'm Jewish I feel like I have a training
for this my whole life
we're meeting the real Santa and that's
pretty kingsnake yeah Santa you're a
wizard well I have been called the
wizard that's real wizard right well you
just born Santa Claus no actually you
know that it hasn't always been the same
human embodiment of the spirit so I tell
you when I was your age I certainly had
no idea I'd be sitting in this seat
today so any of us could become Santa
that's right would I turn white when you
put on the Santa suit you are Santa as
far as any kids are concerned we are
saying a mother applauded no other intro
needed or spent take your clothes off
and dress like Santa Clauses Wow look at
these goofy clown trousers that's pretty
key right hey what's up I'm Santa I
think I put these pants on backwards
unless Santa just puts his hand on his
butt all the time how would be the most
excellent cuddle partner right now
because you know when you think of
Christmas anything about your parents
definitely during Hanukkah
I just thank you for that you're a Leo
if you saw someone wearing this at a
truck stop restroom you wouldn't run in
the other direction as kids we grew up
seeing Santa's outfit and we just
accepted but like this is gaudy as Santa
this guy must be so fat forget the bag
Santa could just stuff all his presents
in here I guess it's back in here like
that Zak all cuddled up by kangaroo baby
do you feel the spirit of giving now you
have a spirit of something Merry
Christmas boys there's one main reason
while never look like Santa Claus he's
hot as [ __ ] great I get to have hair in
my mouth for the rest of the day it's
like I got pubes in the mouth yeah it's
like having a kitty on my face ah do I
look
just like a crazy person oh you go Asian
Santa ready to give you more homework
and the final touch to Santa's outfit
Michael Jackson's gloves
we'll get gloves and I'm Michael Jackson
have a lot in common - look I'm digging
this Asian Santa vibe Oh you been a bad
kid I know you better back it I want you
I love you I want you I sleep let's do
this let's go eat a bunch of cookies and
tell people they're naughty okay Santa
training where do we start
number one is to adopt a don't really
add it and number two is identify people
on the nice list exactly have you been a
good boy this year
never it is a little weird having
another person sit on your lap what are
you doing honey when they're not when
they're just naughty you punish them I
don't even you punish the bad boys you
want to be punished number three is give
as many gifts as you can as quickly as
possible yes the kiddies coming to you
Chloe you're welcome
no meow-meow she's getting too giddy it
seems like it takes a lot of physical
fitness to be Santa can we see those
guns what are you rocking Oh
how many Santas do you remember eat the
cookies and drink a little bit of the
milk
I already feel sick from like three
cookies what if you're lactose
intolerant fake it just fake it for a
little bit of the plant yeah oh okay
feel bad about the plant mostly that
plants gonna die
you four inspire me I mean okay when
you're trying to do what I do I just
hope that I can help in every way that I
can I want to say thank you to the
children all over the world you are
amazing I love you and remember to stay
on that nice list be considerate and be
a Santa's helper
make something for somebody and you'll
be like me you'll be a Santa's helper
have you ever run into trouble sneaking
into someone's house never have
frosty what's up with that guy he's
make-believe but